well the super bowl is always one of the
toughest tickets to get in sports but
somehow three fans
have found a way to get one for every
single super bowl
they call themselves the never missed a
super bowl club pretty cool right
and they will be in the stands in tampa
on sunday jack doyles
joins us live from outside the raymond
james stadium
jack how did they score tickets for this
one
well christian the easy answer is the
nfl hooked them up there was a story
recently in the wall street journal that
stated they didn't have tickets yet
nfl saw that they offered them tickets
at face value about two thousand dollars
and all three jumped at the chance
they'll be at super bowl 55.
it's one of the toughest tickets in
sports but somehow
gregory eaton tom henschel and don
chrisman
have been to every single super bowl
what does this streak mean to you
i don't know how to put it in words
just something i was meant to do i guess
they are three men from three completely
different backgrounds
yet they formed a bond thanks to this
shared experience
don chrisman is a patriots fan from
kennebunkport maine
tom henschel a steelers fan from
pittsburgh while gregory eaton hails
from lansing michigan
he's a lions fan my parents always tell
me you never give
up his lions haven't been to the big
game yet but that hasn't dampened his
enthusiasm for going
in the world series i've been olympics
i've been
cherishing fights with muhammad ali i
followed them all over
morning but this is what i live for each
year
having been to all 54 each has a
favorite
since the patriots and steelers have
each won six it's not hard to figure out
which ones don and tom point to
but gregory has never seen his lions
play in the big game what was the best
super bowl you've been to
the super bowl we had two black head
coaches
in miami it was especially meaningful to
gregory
because of his first super bowl
experience in miami that was
a thrill that i never thought i'd dream
because the first super bowl
in miami i left lansing with five
white businessmen and we got to miami
and they were at the jock
i couldn't stay there i had to stay i
stayed at a black hotel
i tell you what they are well the times
certainly have changed now gregory can
stay
anywhere he wants i did ask him
christian how much he spent on this
pilgrimage to every super bowl the first
year it was a 12
ticket he would not share how much he
spent but if you add up the average
price of every super bowl ticket from 1
to 54
you would have spent over 30 thousand
dollars that does not
include travel lodging and food
so it's a really expensive hobby wow
incredible well let me ask you one more
question
now this isn't your first super bowl as
i can imagine how different is the
atmosphere
because of covert restrictions this year
well normally monday of super bowl week
is media day
and we here at some big stadium filled
with every single player every single
coach the opportunity to talk to him
but this time the chiefs won't get here
until saturday
today's virtual media day so tom brady
was sitting in a room all by himself
answering questions on zoom so yeah a
big impact covert has had
and if you think about this too
christian this
this is the first team to host the super
bowl and play it at the same time
that would be crazy but tampa bay also
had the stanley cup champion
in the tampa bay lightning they played
that in a bubble in canada
tampa bay was also in the world series
the rays they played that in a bubble in
texas
so just think about all the missed
opportunities and missed revenue for
this city
wow thank you so much jack doyle's live
from tampa thank you so much for talking
to us
well you can watch the kansas city
chiefs and the tampa bay bucks
face off in the super bowl right here on
channel 8
this sunday